bella tutte ragazze orofaringe sono qui
con francesco marino ciò oggi è oggi
giocheremo a way out quarta puntata a
voi
larini studi l'ha fatta teologico ogni
parola compresa due prese tu ma che le
ho prese tutte se così davvero religioso
dio che faccio un altro milioni di
contatti e mi scrivo alto canale gran
perfetto ragazzi arrivati a 5 milioni e
mezzo grazie cc adesso stiamo andando a
trovare la famiglia di di leo quindi la
tua famiglia
fatto questo chiedendo una con un mezzo
così non è che poi vi era da un'altra
parte
davvero un sito della madonna del caffè
o al posto giocare a baseball da mila
mazza poiché accorgi che ti devi
toglierti la torre aspetta vai ciccio
famiglia di colpi di fare mai ora in
avanti possibile ok
ecco faccio male come si fa vedere ti
batto adesso assolutamente ciccio di
prenderti in faccia tritto sarà compresa
bravo cinto da raul ciccio pro gamer
bravissimo come si fa a prendere
soltanto va gravissimi ma un fenomeno
grande silenzio ricordo come sei fatto
perché si sfoga meno male che siamo
carcerati e non giocatori di bari l'ex
di bara di ragazzo si chiama ebay mio
figlio
hai vissuto figlio se viene loro venendo
a mio figlio è difficile non vederlo
avrà un naso gigantesche fatti sposa che
non l'abbiamo sola ma comunque lei è una
santa per averti preso lo stonato
ma ora più che altro ma si sono baciati
ci riescono
forse non ci arrivano vediamo come si
sono tenuti a raffica errore di grafica
rientrato il naso nella texture sì sì sì
sì sì molisano
vediamo come alex vediamo stato di mio
figlio aspetto regia di profilo di
profilo no se presto fortunatamente non
è andato malissimo ma anche in questo
caso qua scapperei subito perché non se
lo ricordava avventuroso congo
salve io un'auto normale signora
definito non spaventarlo torino che già
piccolo e parla con alex vieni qua va
aiutato io devo parlare con alex no
vorrei che entrassi pure tu vai entra
entrare a mente perché io ma non mi
piace per tutti gli amanti
io devo aggiustiamo possiamo fare qua
devo prendere ora dai parla a suo figlio
voglio è stato tutta la vita
ecco qua la scena sta scappando è
scappato per una roba brandy all ora
prendo io bambino nello schifo
vieni qua marca vasca a devi andare a
quella della cassazione ad ora il tuo
figlio michael è sceso possa arrivare
alla terra erano un po chicchiera ecco
niente mi hanno proprio escluso dalla
vita
ok alex dopo non la vivo lì ho visto
moggi
che bello sembra gli utenti questa sì
poi no albero
[Musica]
ecco a lorenzo su su betclic e cioè dei
carcerati che giorno a palla va bene
quindi giocherà bene giochiamo a padre
allora fatto è apparso rega niente io
vinco ok set credo fare penso come si
gioca a basket ma non è più bravo lui
l'ha presa
caro michele però le parole però non è
ancora lui ancora lui
stephen curry no no no prendo io lo
prendevo michael john michael jordan era
sono aspettati aspettate succede però si
sa ne arrivò subito ma come si sa come
sei rimasto aspetta un attimo blog e
chiariva del tutto di amazon a lorenzo
non c'è ragazzi probabilmente questa
parte non ammetterà però voglio dire
lorenzo è un bravo ragazzo ma degli
iscritti ha però guarda del cuore che
sta facendo e che sa perché è detto
bambino dove stai detto sto dicendo
guardate così appello lo penso io
naturalmente lungo di cristo mama said
zitto zitto chiusa libro by amazon senti
bambino basta bravo basta stare qua
tutta la vita inizia a sgomberi è uguale
agli utili e più viste lo giuro i
pantaloni e scarpe uguale per artur
identico
tra fece presto ma fuori curio mob
ok
e stato bello
chiedi naso bond di chi di naso abbonda
di profondo cosa senti va bene miliardi
lavora qua bluff minaccia velata
minaccia ma dai mini my friends with one
walking the widow bosh wade a torino si
ok andiamo facciamo il culo
va bene mi spiace per la r abbiamo
trattato un po male era un bravo ragazzo
ero presenza di malware
madame gigante guarda quanti gross un
cantiere americano
nato da niente minchia ora quante grosso
un cantiere americano è veramente grosso
stai facendo braccio di ferro con cosa
con l'aria stai giocando con l'aria neri
con mezzo né seiver palle a posto e
penso sempre come o fuori oddio
questo è tutto allenamento che ho fatto
due ragazze questo non è stato difficile
anche per me se devo essere sincero
andiamo allora va bene sarà sulla cima
del palazzo tipo alla fine a sopra
[Musica]
insomma vai vai vai premio premio che
dobbiamo menarlo prendi lo prendo io dai
ciccio dai 26 avrebbero io ti pare si
potevano arrivare in modo un po più
stealth in modo tale da non farlo
scappare no come faccio porca vacca
prendi che la madonna mi sono fatto
malissimo
mi sono fatto veramente male non fa
nulla
beh io premio cantina trentina va bene
ecco avevo così preso marca vacca ma la
provincia sono stanco dei vivai tirati
su e lo abbiamo chiamato tuffa scusami
eh non lo so bella domanda attenzione a
tutti di marca vacca e come faccio a
pentiti dall'autostrada premio perché la
cavo così preso ma a dedizione per un
millimetro macello prenderlo ciccio con
ricordi adesso cosa so cosa sto correndo
lo vedo là sotto
mamma mia sono sopra il sensore
attenzione quindi faccio io no che
ora storia ma tutto arriva tutto
arrivando dal fatto che il fatto è che
non è che siamo proprio
io sono sopra l'ascensore pensate quanto
soffro di vertigini quello amicizia mi
piacciono abbiamo fatto batman scemi
andato davanti all ex post per fermarci
sono io sono una che nate io è andato
davanti a una porta sola andiamo l'acqua
perché lo cerca adesso quali saranno
seduti sulla trama ma sa che c'è gente
lo ama ma cazzo fa ma sono pazzi no e mi
caccerei fortissimo cose qua sta
nascondendo qui lui la che brutta roba
eccesso in eccesso ciao non era cosa sta
accadendo dentro una cassa l'acqua è
scontento hai trovato to maledizione 3
pari che sa trovare per riprendersi
guardato insieme
vai ok cervello senza mai
[Musica]
no no non mi piace ai naso per queste
cose e io ti avvicini alla gru poco alti
alza abbassa anche mai alzati certo per
la grappa diagramma di poker ai 60 e
figo o le vai vai se arrivato mamma mia
destra ascensore ma occhio che ti tira
una testa paura o italia lavoro è sempre
dietro quando non lo trova eccolo qua e
io come faccio tech che madonna che
cartella la scala alla scala anche
perché con la cava si scusa sto vedendo
lì poi sono scemo io dovevo andare
scusami come sta andando
accendi con la prova in francese a
santoro dall'altra parte dell'arma se
voleste scemo
secondo te io arrivo fino alla gu mashai
asi tranquillo vado io dormo
forse ci arrivo ma ci metterò tantissimo
oh mio dio
eccolo eccolo che arriva questo figlio
dovrebbe dedizione non lo so lo re
quanto sei bravo e non saltare mai state
già arrivo ciao allora moglie ed è che
questa pagnottella aia che male questo è
immortale ma dobbiamo ucciderlo
no hyatt e male
compito della mia mano sono ancora vivo
impossibile pazzo carri cavalca vieni
qua ci vieni favorire o le hai rotto le
balle tra vasta quanto quanto mi sta
mettendo alle strette sono brava a
prendere rapidamente l'ho dimostrato
prima e vabbè mirror's edge e ben 262
sopra stupide secondo te ma ecco così
che devo fare
tu vai da una parte e dall'altra
importazioni carica se non convince a 70
[Musica]
canzone bellissima
e stato stupendo no per il segmento più
bello della vita ma veramente o
l'abbiamo legato aiutarli pugni è questo
qua era vantato farò un bel voto da un
po tutto questo come facile dove spicca
bello farlo mamma mia che belgio
spingilo posso farlo davvero non è vero
facciamo questa cosa è bellissimo c'è
quanto siamo stati vicini
ecco questo è brutto ma si aspetta
aspetta a farlo parlare con una torcia
spiegano cosa puoi fare
picchia sapete se fa restando che manco
io si sta parlando perché messico è
piccolo ma andiamo in messico a caso
prima ancora in gara i poliziotti del
carcere perché noi non possiamo andare
in messico avessi è vero perché sono
carcerati magorno adirano vecchietto
sgonico nemica
perfette della chiesa la casa di mia
nonna l'accordo ragazzi tra un cazzeggio
e l'altro abbiamo scoperto dove la casa
di harvey e quindi possiamo andare a
farli il culetto così si spera quindi io
concludo questo episodio di way out ci
vediamo tra un paio di giorni con il
fatto siamo arrivati vi sembra non lo so
comunque ci rivediamo tra pochi giorni
poi si inserisce quanto mi piace anche
vari secondi notizia che si chiede e noi
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video da
ragazzi
[Musica]